[Music]
thank you everyone thank you and welcome
to the interval thanks so much for
coming out tonight
for Jonathan Keats this is gonna be a
fantastic talk I'm really glad for you
to be here so this is this is a really
fun night for us because we actually
have a lot of friends in the audience a
lot of present and future speakers for
us in the audience
Rachel Sussman is here tonight who is
actually our second speaker ever in this
series before we were even officially
open
and she's also spoken in our main long
now series we're thrilled that she could
be here tonight we have our next two
speakers after tonight on April 21st
Patrick house who's here is going to be
speaking about how modern research on
brain parasites can connects with
ancient Egypt and tells us things about
schizophrenia and and it also involves
cats so I I love trying to summarize our
speakers we have amazing topics it's
going to be incredible talk and we also
have Dee Fox Harrell here tonight and
Fox who's from MIT and is also here in
the area for a bit working with the
Center for an Advanced Study in the
behavioral sciences casbahs at Stanford
this is a new partnership and we're
gonna have a whole series of talks Fox
is our first talk in that series and
that will be coming up on May 5th and
but to get to tonight's talk it's enough
part of another great partnership that
we have zero one from San Jose our great
arts and technology organization this is
the second talk that we've put together
with them
and I want to bring up Jamie Austin now
from 0 1 to talk a little bit more about
what they do and tonight's speaker
Jonathan Keith super big round of
applause for Jamie thank you hi everyone
I'm Jamie Austin I'm the curator and
director of programs at 0 1 and we're a
silicon valley-based arts organization
where art meets technology to shape the
future and we're excited we've been
partnering with the long now foundation
to help kind of seed artists into this
talk series that's looking at art time
and technology and as Michael said this
is the second talk that we've been able
to partner on here so thank you all for
joining us both of our organizations are
really focused on interdisciplinary
practice and I'm sure most of you think
of yourselves as cross-disciplinary
interdisciplinary multidisciplinary
which is why you're here and interested
in these sorts of topics so thank you
and that's certainly something that we
all celebrate at 0 1 our goal is to
really support risk-taking artists who
are thinking deeply about societal and
cultural challenges and changing the way
that we see the world so speaking about
seeing and about vision I'm very excited
tonight to be able to introduce San
Francisco based artist and experimental
philosopher Jonathan Keats Jonathan is
an artist who I love meeting for coffee
because every time I do he blows my mind
and I just have to think about what he's
told me for quite a long time and he's
someone that we've been you know talking
about projects with for years and fits
so perfectly with what long now is doing
here tonight he will be sharing his
century and millennial or millennium
camera projects with you among others
and also give you a hands-on opportunity
to test out his technology which is kind
of this interesting combination of old
and new and looking at long-term effects
and short-term actions that we can
to connect the two so there's a hands-on
element that everyone gets to
participate in at the end if you so
choose and tonight he'll also throw in
topics like space and cloning maybe not
cats but I am a fan of those too but he
has a lot of great projects to share
with you tonight so please join me in
welcoming Jonathan Keats Thank You Jamie
thank you Michael within the next thirty
minutes I'm going to tell you what I
will be doing for the next five thousand
years but I want to start with something
a little more modest to tell you about
the time that I sat in a chair and
thought for 24 hours the year was 2000
and I had this idea that I wanted to be
an artist and didn't really know how to
make anything like painting or drawing
or the various skills that one is
supposed to have so I figured that
perhaps I should get into conceptual art
and as I explored that possibility the
more that I looked into it the more than
I found that conceptual artists seemed
to be sort of cheating a little bit in
terms of there was a concept but it was
also instantiated in all of these things
these objects so I heard that I could
outdo that there was no reason why I
shouldn't be able to and while maybe in
retrospect this all seems a little bit
pretentious I decided that what I would
do is that I would make conceptual art
that was purely conceptual and that
naturally involved thinking so what I
did was I persuaded a gallery refusal on
that that South of Market or was Once
Upon a Time in San Francisco I persuaded
them to give me a chair and to let me
think for 24 hours straight so to think
for 24 hours straight and in order to
make this rigorous I had a factory time
clock that was set up and I would take a
time card and I would punch
I would sit down think of thought when I
thought it I would then punch out and
then punch it on the next one
and I went on like this for a full 24
hours but of course I wanted people to
understand and I wanted myself to think
of this as art so as a result I felt
that I needed to contextualise
appropriately so I had alternately a
still-life bowl of fruit set up or a
model who was posing nude and the
thoughts that I had over that time span
were the artwork and if you wanted to
purchase one of these works you could do
so by going to the dealer and revealing
your annual income and the dealer would
then prorate my thoughts so that you
would pay minute for a minute for my
thoughts whatever it was that you
yourself were paid you didn't get much
for this as I said earlier I really
wanted to make this conceptual and so
therefore what you did get was you got
the factory timecard punched as a
receipt no information whatsoever about
what it was that I had thought because
that wouldn't be the thought it would be
a representation of it and they would
get everything completely mixed up so I
could perhaps have gone on like this
24 hours 48 hours insanity I could have
perhaps had some sort of a career as a
conceptual artist but somehow I just
didn't have it in me somehow it just did
not seem sufficient and what did seem
interesting to me was the way in which
it related back to what I thought I was
going to become before I decided that I
was going to be have a conceptual artist
and that was a philosopher now my idea
of being a philosopher was the same sort
of idea that all of you had at three or
four years old which was that you think
about things and you talk about them and
it's all this very kind of open-ended
great conversation so I went off to
school I studied philosophy and found
that it was all very interesting and
well worthwhile but the sorts of things
that we were
talking about in the ways we were doing
so well my parents didn't seem
particularly interested and that told me
something there was something I think
that was happening there that had much
more potential than what was happening
within the realm of professional
philosophy and I wanted to find a way to
do that to find a way back to that sort
of naive idea a philosophy that I had as
a child and I realized that what I had
been doing sitting in that gallery
thinking for 24 hours might be a way
forward that is to say that it is since
what I was doing was I was not only
selling art not doing a very good job of
it by the way I think we did about $75
worth of business in the entire 24 hours
but I was also in the case of this
project I think that I was thinking
about thought there was a way in which
when you try to make a thought manifest
by way of his time card when he tried to
make it a commodity it calls to mind all
sorts of thoughts about what is a
thought and so I came to start thinking
of this as a sort of a thought
experiment
I thought experiments were something
that I learned about in school and they
interested me very much and they were
also kind of disappointing he's a
thought experiment generally speaking
was something that you would do in a
journal in the way of a sort of an
exercise and argumentation taking a
counterfactual that was very obviously
so as a way of being able to make your
own point I never had any point that was
what was interesting to me about
philosophy was that it was about
questions and I've always been sort of
allergic to answers except as a way of
getting to more questions so I always
thought that a thought experiment ought
to be genuinely experimental that there
should be a way in which to undertake
that thought experiment out in the world
in a way that it would be totally
open-ended and that the conclusion would
be something that was discovered and so
I came to start thinking of myself as an
experimental philosopher and took that
as my new job to give you a few examples
what sorts of things an experimental
philosopher does and there's exactly one
of us that I'm aware of it what one good
example probably is from a few years ago
when I went into time management now a
lot of people have done that before and
there's a lot of money to be made
Franklin Colby for instance is a great
example and definitely you don't want to
try to compete with them but at the same
time what they were doing seemed to me
to be somehow not really what they
claimed they were doing and none of the
other time management services or
companies did either because they
weren't really managing time they were
managing you in fact what they were
doing was making you work harder or
faster and get less sleep and be more
miserable and generally speaking they
were either convincing you that you
wanted to do that or they were
convincing your company that this was a
way in which to coerce you to do so and
none of that really seemed to me like it
has anything to do whatsoever with
managing time but at the same time I
realized that there was a way in which
you could manage time and that we had
already the science to do it for a
hundred years of course I'm talking
about relativity I'm talking about
Einstein time dilation is one of the
inherent qualities in relativity that
where you have gravitation there's a
warp in time that your time relative to
a frame of reference to another another
place where you have less of a
gravitational attraction or less mass
that your the time is going to be moving
more slowly well that seems like the
basis for some sort of time management
that you could use gravity to manage
time by way of time dilation where where
you had more gravity and where others
had less gravity your time would be
moving more slowly relative to them and
so I decided that I would try to market
this and I did so by creating time
ingots it seemed logical enough I
founded a company
spacetime industries and the timing gets
worried as you can see well there were
bars of LED that I bought on eBay and I
packaged them though and the thing about
this technology is that you could very
conveniently put one of these on your
desk and you would have as your frame of
reference ever-so-slight an advantage
over the person in the next cubicle
so granted we're talking about a very
very small advantage but then I realized
there were many other ways in which to
use this sort of advantage that came
courtesy of gravity and of mr. Einstein
namely you could have what I came to
call the time warp undershirt a time
warp undershirt puts greater density
more mass around your heart relative to
the rest of your body especially your
brain and as a result you end up with
this very slight advantage of living
just that little bit longer relative to
how long you think you're living or you
get to think a little bit faster or
relative to how long you're living I
will grant you that this is a minimal
effect we're talking about perhaps
billionth of a billionth of maybe a
billionth of a second over the course of
the entire length of time that the
universe has been here so you really
need in order to be able to feel this
and to take advantage of this in a
serious way you need well you need a
neutron star so that's what I came up
with as a way to move forward in this
technology namely I came up with a sort
of an architecture that can be built on
neutron stars what I called an elevator
house and the concept of the elevator
house was basically that every room was
on a shaft and you could arrange your
life by the way that you arranged the
rooms on these different shafts so as to
be able to fully manage your time and of
course up on the roof is the garden
where plants are growing relatively
quickly compared to your life and you're
able therefore to have strawberries as
many as you want whenever you want them
but this is all still sort of
selfish and still sort of not fully
managing time to the full potential I
don't believe I think the work gets
interesting is where it gets communal
that is to say not to manage time just
for yourself but what if an entire
community
had time management in this relativistic
way well I decided to design some cities
I decided to go into urban planning why
not have an experimental philosopher
after all and so what I did was I
designed a few cities now for my cities
what I did was I used the equivalents of
velocity to mass because it was easier
at least it was easier to make some
blueprints and so I ended up with cities
like this the cities have different
districts that are spinning very very
fast but at different rates relative to
each other those of you who know clock
making are able probably to figure out
that what's going on right here is that
the residential district is spinning at
a rate that is going to give you a
relatively long life span compared to
those are trees that's the agricultural
district on the other side so you get to
eat well and in the middle is the
industrial district which frankly we do
need our iPhones and other plastic
things but not too many of them so it
seemed like it really belongs in the
middle and so I then went ahead and I
came up with some other cities that
could also be built along these lines
and submitted these out into the world
totally open source for any government
that wished to take it on and to build
one of these nobody's done it yet I have
to tell you but it is also interesting
to me that it got quite a lot of
attention
that for instance arket Iser one of the
architectural trade publications wrote
it up and not only them but also the
Wall Street Journal and this is
interesting to me I mean not only is it
a excuse for me to boast it also is
interesting from the standpoint of what
I was talking about earlier namely how
to do philosophy in public in a way that
engages people in a broad conversation
where what it's about kind of comes out
of the conversation itself
so that you end up with in the case of a
project like this all sorts of things
falling out of it all sorts of ideas
that I certainly didn't have going into
it and I probably ended up stealing from
other people as I was having
conversations with them but really in
terms of how we think about time in our
society and the way in which the
arrangement of time and the
understanding of time and communal terms
fundamentally changes time as
experienced and how society can be built
in ways perhaps not using quite the same
amount of elaborate clockwork as I have
done but in ways that might be truer to
the relationship that we have through
time just to give you quickly another
example of the sort of thing that I do
as an experimental philosopher I I got
interested in in in time travel and
thinking about for instance how would
you get Napoleon here now well you can't
do it very easily he's dead for instance
but I figured out that you actually
could sort of do it if you were to clone
him but cloning in its own right has all
sorts of problems and I'm not just
talking about the ethics I'm talking
about the practicality of it and so I
didn't want to get into any of that
because I don't really have any
background in biology for instance so I
realized that there was actually a much
easier way to go about it but none of
the cloning agencies that I was aware of
were actually undertaking and that was
that within genetics
increasingly there is attention to an
interest in in epigenetics epigenetics
is effectively the turning on and off of
genes as a result of how you experience
the world around you toxins and food and
all of these various chemicals in
particular are affecting which genes are
expressed and when so if you take for
instance a pair of twins at birth you
can't tell them apart probably but at
age 20 you
probably can and a teach 60 you most
certainly can they start to even if they
are identical they start not to be
identical and that is courtesy of
epigenetics so what if you were to take
that and do the opposite what if you
were instead of having a sort of
divergence have a convergence what if
you were to become Napoleon
epigenetically that is to say my idea
was in starting this cloning agency that
I would provide the means for you to
become Napoleonic and that meant taking
in a lot of chemicals that you probably
don't want to because the polian as I
researched it turns out that he eat a
chicken every day with the skin on so a
lot of cholesterol he also was shot on
the battlefield
lead is something that you need to take
in that's the the white container there
you also will need some arsenic and some
mercury B as those were considered to be
cures for things back in the day and so
if you were to take these you could
epigenetically speaking by turning on
and off your genes become napoleon or
more more like napoleon and you can do
this not only for Napoleon of course you
can also do it for for instance that
Jesus Christ would be relatively easy as
well taking a Mediterranean diet would
be certainly a part of it but also you
would certainly want a lot of iron given
the nails and all that and so there
becomes this enormous potential out
there and becomes even more interesting
when you think about what happens when
you start mixing and matching Napoleon
and Jesus Christ mixed into a single
character and you can do it just by
taking all of these noxious chemicals
well noxious and nobody has done it but
once again there has been considerable
interest including in nature in this
instance that has come about I believe
through this sort of
conversation that happens around this
experiment which is really a thought
experiment that when you start thinking
about cloning and epigenetics in this
way you start to think about identity in
more fluid ways and you also even start
to think about about history in more
fluid ways if in fact we no longer have
the determinacy genetically speaking
that is what leads us to think of one
generation leading to another if there
is some sort of a way in which there's
more flux does it fundamentally change
our ideas about time and our sense of
history itself so all of that is in the
past what I want to do now is to talk to
you about the future and for me the
future began last year in Berlin that is
where I decided to develop a camera with
an exposure time of 100 years now the
camera is not your ordinary device it's
not your iPhone for instance it is in
fact the simplest of cameras because
anything complicated it is liable to
break and I probably couldn't make it
anyway so what I have done
starting in Berlin was to make a camera
that is a pinhole camera in other words
it's a camera that lets in very little
light through a pinhole that is focused
onto what ordinarily would be a piece of
film well any film is going to spoil
relatively quickly I've managed to with
my own cyanotype chemistry make
exposures that are on the order of
perhaps a week and I know people who
have managed to do so I believe up to a
couple years through various tricks and
that's well and good but it certainly is
by no means a century so the way in
which this camera works is it doesn't
use ordinary film it uses something much
more common and much more simple which
is ordinary black paper now if you think
about a book on your coffee table for
and you look at it you'll see that it
probably has started to fade or a poster
on your wall and it will continue to do
so in sunlight well the same thing will
happen for a piece of ordinary black
paper but if you put that paper into a
camera letting in very little light
through a pinhole what you're doing is
you're projecting the scene in front of
a camera but light is projected on to
the paper in a way that the paper will
gradually bleach very very slowly taking
in an image the image will not be static
because presumably whatever you're
photographing is going to change over
that 100-year period so if you think
about if the camera is out in a city and
there are some small houses and those
houses get torn down after 20 years and
a skyscraper gets built up in their
place and is there for the for the next
80 just to simplify you would see the
shadow a ghost of those houses against
the boulder skyscraper sort of like in
sports photography when you see a
basketball player moving very fast
across a court where the court is very
boldly in place in view and the
basketball player is sort of ghostly and
so what you end up with is not so much a
photograph is you end up with a movie
all in a single frame of that full span
of a hundred years now why that
interested me and Berlin was watching
the city undergoing rapid and rampant
development so incredibly fast that
every time that I went back there it was
as if it were a different city and so I
was started to think about how you might
make a camera that would be able to take
that in that would serve as a sort of a
surveillance camera in the hands of
those most affected by everything that
we do all the decisions that we make it
least powerful to make any decisions
that is to say those not yet formed and
so the idea in Berlin was to build these
cameras as surveillance cameras that
could be taken out into the field and
hidden away
in a hundred years the images would be
brought in so I worked with a gallery
called team Titanic
we built a hundred of them and we then
made them available to anyone who wanted
to take one and to hide it if he wanted
to take one you gave a deposit of 10
euros took a camera hid it somewhere
anywhere that you wanted in Berlin
didn't tell anybody except when he got
to be very old you would tell a child
where you had put it or you would write
it into your will and in a hundred years
those children then grown up would bring
the cameras back to team Titanic where
they would get the 10 euro deposit no
guarantees about what it's worth but
nevertheless you would get something in
return and then there would be an
exhibition a hundred years of change all
in that image and so the idea was really
to engage people to engage the children
of today in a way that they were
actively taking a part in putting these
cameras out in the world and not only
those who were directly involved but
also those who heard about it who read
about it and it was all over the place
we got it into the newspapers we got a
conversation going about this that the
cameras became a sort of a constant
presence and remain for the next hundred
years a sort of constant presence in the
city I think them as sort of black boxes
in that sense that are documenting and
therefore are well it's a sort of
documentary photography in the worst
possible way because documentary
photographers are not supposed to
interfere these photographs manifestly
do interfere because you don't know
where they are and yet you know that you
could be being watched and so the
decisions that you make you perhaps feel
a little bit more accountable for those
and perhaps feel some sort of a
relationship to those in the far future
well of course Berlin isn't the only
city undergoing rapid gentrification and
transformation we're in one right now
and that is why in collaboration with a
long now foundation we are going to be
bringing in this project to San
Francisco and I am hoping that all of
you will participate tonight after the
talk we are going to have the supplies
for all of you to make these cameras and
to go and to hide them out in the city
and in a hundred years I have been
assured that there will be an exhibition
at the interval I will not be here to
give a talk about it but there will be
an exhibition where the results of these
will be visible for all but I didn't
stop there and so I won't stop talking
now we'll get back to the hundred-year
camera later on when you'll have the
chance to build them I I continue to get
more ambitious and figured well if
you've got a hundred years then why not
a thousand well a thousand years is a
larger number than a hundred and
therefore there are different issues
different problems that have to be
addressed namely the sort of tin can
that I'm showing you right there whether
it lasts for a hundred years is
definitely debatable and we could debate
it later a thousand years though I think
that I probably would have to agree with
you that there's not much chance so I
started to ransack fields that know a
little bit about time that is to say
archaeology and art conservation and I
use those as the basis for building a
camera that could make an exposure 1,000
years in length so the camera has a body
that is built out of pure copper a metal
that we know very well over long periods
of time that it takes on a patina that
serves as a protective surface that
prevents further corrosion all of which
is well and good except for when you
start thinking about the pinhole itself
which you don't want any corrosion
whatsoever happening and so therefore
the pinhole is pierced through a plate
of 24 karat gold the film is probably
the trickiest part black paper maybe is
not the best way to go but we do know
that oil painting lasts for a very long
time
and we also know that oil painting at
least older oil paints organic paints
are problematic they have what is called
inherent vice which is the bane of
existence for every art conservator but
for me was actually the way in which I
could go about solving this problem that
is to say that that was potentially
advantageous if I were to take one of
these pigments that we knew would fade
over a long time that is in this case a
pigment that is known as Rose madder
which is made from a root and has been
used for thousands of years and I were
to use an oil paint made out of that
where we know that this oil paint has
been used for more than 500 years and in
fact has been used on copper because we
have Renaissance copper paintings and
where we know a lot about how those
paintings were made I then was able to
go and to make the camera which involves
some rather curious ingredients one of
which is you have to rub the copper in
garlic before you start painting on it
but I can build cameras that had this
that was a year-long exposure and so the
first one I built I just put up in
Arizona at Arizona State University
built into the wall of the Arizona State
University Art Museum and they have the
camera on a thousand year loan there is
paperwork they have to return it but the
photograph is donated to them at the end
of the thousand years and already has a
3015 accession number assigned to it so
that was the first wonder the second one
I am next week going to Amherst
Massachusetts
to Amherst College to install one at the
Meade Art Museum and that will go in an
old steeple and it will not be looking
out as in the case of the Arizona one on
a city but we're looking out on the
Holyoke mountain range which is
relatively speaking a natural
environment with many many microclimates
and so you see two more or less
identical cameras two very different
sorts of pictures that I'm setting out
to take and that is fully intentional
because I think that when you move from
a hundred years to a thousand things get
interesting in different ways you're no
longer talking about some sort of a
direct generational kind of handoff
anymore what you're talking about
instead is looking into deep time that
is to say you're looking at the way in
which the things that we do now by way
of how they affect the environment they
how they affect the climate for example
will change what happens and how people
live or don't in the far future and
cities are potentially that future
there's a good argument we made that
cities have the efficiency that allows
for people to live sustainably in the
long term that would not exist in any
other sort of arrangement but at the
same time cities are highly perilous
because they're incredibly wasteful and
having a city that is in Arizona where
you have chronic water shortage is
particularly perilous and yet Tempe
seems to me a particularly interesting
case because it is both of those things
and also because it's a city that is
forming of its own momentum out of
suburbia in a way that I think cities
are likely to do so in that case we're
looking at a city in the other case
we're looking at what we might call
nature though that is always of course
arguable we are looking at the way in
which vegetation changes over deep time
and so we have a gamut here we have a
way in which through these cameras which
I hope are only the first two of many
that can be defined through this gamut
to be in many places around the world we
have this way in which these cameras are
allowing us to to look into the far
future and look back upon ourselves from
the far future because the fact is that
we are biologically really not equipped
to think in deep time because deep time
has never been something we've had - or
been able to grapple with the hand axe
which is basically the technology that
we evolved with to the extent that we
evolved with any technology you couldn't
really chain
change the climate over thousands or
tens of thousands of years we now have
the technological means to do so but we
are evolutionarily speaking nowhere in a
place that we know how to grapple with
that sort of power so I think that maybe
what we need are mental Pro species and
I think that they can be technological
and I think that a camera like this a
thousand year camera can provide that as
a way at this monumental scale looking
into the future where we can see the
future in our imagination imagining what
is happening on that film in order then
to project ourselves into that future
looking back on ourselves to have a sort
of a feedback loop and those cameras I
believe can operate in conjunction with
a hundred-year cameras and I believe all
this needs to be taken up by UNESCO
because frankly I've run out of space in
my apartment and I think that UNESCO
could do this in a way that would be
very inexpensive by having 100-year
cameras such as the one that I've used
as the design for my poster at Amherst
College that would be incredibly
inexpensive and therefore could be
ubiquitous they're made out of cardboard
yes a hundred years is a lot to ask of a
piece of cardboard but go to the library
and you'll see plenty of cardboard and
paper that has lasted longer than that
so that technically is not really a
problem you can make it you can expect
very few of them to last and if you make
this a birthright where every child gets
one of these cameras and the cameras go
out into the world you're going to have
billions of these cameras out there and
in a hundred years they're going to
start coming in every day and there
could be an exhibition every day this
worldwide view showing the hundred years
of change and yet at the same time with
more cameras going out and this sort of
iterative process that builds a sort of
relationship that we might have with
those who will come after us well at the
same time the thousand year cameras as a
sentinels built into every city as he
sort of monumental cameras can provide
that longer-term view that we can have
all of that kind of working within our
mind all simultaneously now for those of
you keeping account I haven't yet gotten
to five thousand years and I'm already
over thirty minutes but if you'll allow
me just to
and humor one more idea one more project
that I would like to leave you with that
is what I am planning to do next and I
haven't yet talked about this this is
the first time that I am saying anything
at all about it
what I am planning to do is to create a
calendar there are a lot of those as the
Gregorian calendar for example and the
calendars that we have are very regular
they are more regular than the spin of
the planet
they're certainly more regular than life
on Earth and so that got me thinking
about whether you could have a different
kind of a calendar a calendar that would
in fact be true to life in terms of the
fact that it would keep time according
to how life was lived on this planet
well those calendars are actually all
around us they're called trees and trees
will grow a ring every year and the
girth of that ring is determined by
climate by rainfall weather patterns and
so forth but we don't tend to see them
in that way unless we saw them down and
to me it seems that you could in fact
make a tree operate as a calendar by
taking that tree and I am proposing a
Bristlecone pine a tree with a 5,000
year lifespan and putting milestones
around it well not exactly milestones
but since free stones or stone to the
500 year period between stones set at
regular intervals according to if the
calendar if the tree were to grow at the
rate that it is right now where would it
be in 500 years at that point it will
grow large enough that because of its
strength it will turn over that stone
and a thousand years and so forth up to
five thousand but of course they will
fall out of sync it won't it won't work
out that that five hundred years will be
the same five hundred years as you have
marked on your Gregorian calendar and to
me that is where it really gets
interesting because I don't know which
calendar in that case
we would say was right I don't know how
we would account for time if we had
these two different kinds of calendars
that were simultaneously keeping time
one of which was celestial one of which
was abstract and the other of which was
manifestly manifestly terrestrial and
was really about the world as we exist
in it the world in which we are living
in now so where to get a Bristlecone
pine well it just so happens that I know
some people who have more than one of
them the long now foundation happens to
have this space more than a space it's
800 odd acres in Eastern Nevada Mount
Washington they bought it back in the
90s and it just so happens to have the
world's largest Bristlecone pine forest
in private hands this is the ideal space
and I've already started talking with
the long now foundation about how we
might implement this to put the calendar
there that would be able for the next
five in five thousand years to keep time
on our planet it's going to take a lot
of work it's going to take really
getting out there into the world to
attempt to make this come about but the
more that I think about it the more that
it seems worthwhile then sitting and
thinking in a chair thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Jonathan so this is the world
premiere of this and is what's the the
official is there an official name for
the we are calling it as centuries of
the Bristlecone centuries of the
Bristlecone so this is the zip this is
year there's the grand revealing of it
there so a lot of details to be worked
out yes we have 5000 years plus ahead of
us yeah so look forward to those
committee meetings they're gonna be
fantastic so thank you so much so we're
gonna take your questions in a second
one thing we hadn't really touched on
that I wanted to just quickly do is
we've got a couple of your books in the
back sure I write books too
you know being an experimental
philosopher is not the best way to make
a living so I also found the second
worst way to make a living and so these
are two of my most recent books both
published by Oxford University Press one
of which is on the coevolution of
science language and technology based on
my work for Wired magazine where I write
the jargon watch column every month and
the other one is making an argument that
art forgeries are the great art of our
time and it's a long argument I don't
know that I agree with it but
nevertheless I put it out there as a
manifesto and as an advertisement for
myself fantastic
so who has a question for for Jonathan
do we have in the back so the question
is for people to be able to see the
images which are currently trapped in a
small chamber as they're evolving yes so
two answers there because there was
implicit in that question another
question that you didn't know you were
asking but I'll take it as a chance to
answer it anyway and that is to do with
accessibility one thing that I have
thought about in terms of making these
cameras is how to make them where you
can make no assumptions whatsoever about
where we will be technologically
speaking at 100 let alone a thousand
yes that is to say that if we were to
use your your iPhone for instance
probably nobody would know how to
operate it then so the cameras not only
are not digital but they make an image
without any need for post-processing at
all the image fades into the camera so
that the moment you open it it's there
you don't need any sort of technology in
place other than some sort of a set of
eyes and I leave even compound eyes
would do the trick
so that doesn't answer your question to
answer your question yes absolutely it
is something that could be done all of
this is open source and I would urge you
to do it I think that the more ways in
which this is undertaken the greater the
plurality of it the better that said
that isn't the way that I've got about
it because I think that what we really
need as I said earlier is a mental
process that allows us to operate and to
think in deep time and I think that
being able to open that camera and look
inside becomes much more of a
technological or visual experience and
much less of a psychological one at the
level of being able to envision and
being able to imagine and through that
imagination being able to change being
able even to act rather foolishly in the
sense of being overly optimistic what
could be inside that camera could be
quite grim but your belief that it is
not so bad
maybe would make it so that you would be
less likely just to go along with it
I don't know but I think that there is a
way in which having the cameras
inaccessible for that full thousand
years or a hundred years works a lot
better and also it takes me off the hook
you know hey we're we're we're very much
in beta here a hundred years we can
start to talk about the bracketing
process and I won't be around and so I
am NOT going to be blamed all right
other questions for Jonathan
so as an experimental philosopher so you
as far as you know you're the only
practicing experimental philosopher I
stole this as most things from a very
old job title there were natural
philosophers and there also were
sometimes experimental philosophers back
several centuries ago and it was never
quite clear which was which I don't
think that there really was a
distinction but I didn't I've always had
a fondness for natural philosophy as a
sort of a dilettante to enterprise and
as you can all tell by now I am a
dilettante that's why my business cards
say untitled and so that sort of
universal curiosity was something that
was present in those who called
themselves natural philosophers or
experimental philosophers way back and I
would like to try to bring that into the
present not only for myself but to urge
others also to become experimental
philosophers and to undertake these
sorts of open-ended public conversations
through what they do following following
your curiosity I thought do you want to
soak em to their senses over over time
what's I have thought about sound in
particular and looking at clockwork and
there are some people who know a bit
more about clockwork than I do but
looking at ways in which clockwork and
magnetism might operate over if not a
thousand years but actually a thousand
years at least over a hundred years it
seems that in concept it would be
relatively trivial to describe this in
terms of building it probably it would
be considerably more difficult I think
that why it doesn't interest me as much
as what happens with photography is
because it is manifestly temporal in its
own right and I think that the question
that that would need to be asked would
be is there a way in which to allow
sound
to accrue that it was not just a really
long 8-track tape is there a way in
which sound could pile on top of sound
and that there could be some sort of a
renormalizing process perhaps that would
make it so it just didn't get more and
more noisy but that you would end up
with some sort of a layered sound it
makes me as I'm riffing here it makes me
think of what John Adams did for the
sound of the atomic bomb at the end of
dr. atomic where he made this sound by
layering all the sounds he could
possibly find and this was I think very
interesting in a conceptual way in terms
of how to think about sound but it was
this incredibly complex sound built out
of all these sounds and so perhaps the
cameras can give some sort of a clue
into how we might think about recording
sound in a way that would not be either
recorded for a hundred years and then
speed it up and have everyone speaking
like Mickey Mouse or recorded for a
hundred years and have to then spend the
next hundred years listening to some
really boring stuff but again this is
all put out there in the world for
everyone to engage and to attempt to
find other ways to go about it because
they're there I don't claim to have any
creativity I simply seem to be the
cheapest labor available and have a
naivete to think that doing something
like this is worthwhile and when I do it
I find that people congregate around it
I find that interesting ideas come about
so a quick question for folks who
haven't followed you before how what's
the best way for people to track what
you are doing next I am terrible at that
sort of thing so I show at modernism
gallery in San Francisco once a year or
at least so far they have tolerated that
and I hope that they will continue to do
so and anyone who wishes to leave email
contact I can put you onto that mailing
list it's a very good question how to
make experimental philosophy a viable
profession
and I guess one answer is that society
doesn't have to if people will only do
it on their own that's not a good answer
but that is an answer and the reason
that I want to give that as my initial
answer is first of all because that's
what I do and I can speak from
experience and second because I am wary
of the way in which these things change
as they become institutionalized I as I
said I have a lot of interest in
professional philosophy as done in
academia and I've remained in contact
with those people and they don't totally
hate me but at the same time it seems to
me that the the obligations in place
when you start to build something
institutionally in terms of
accountability in terms of the sort of a
relationships that need to be formalized
in some sense those are going to ossify
the exploratory process that I believe
is the essence of experimental
philosophy that said certainly society
can do a lot more and I think that
you're seeing it here with along now I
think you're seeing it was zero one I
think you're seeing it with foundations
that are remarkably hands-off in terms
of what they let you get away with that
they figured out that it has more to do
with curating people than with
shepherding ideas and the great problem
in what is often called sy art is that
it tends to end up with some powerful
scientific institution saying we need
some illustrations of what we're doing
and we don't really want spend a lot of
money okay so we'll get an artist we'll
give them a residency and they'll do it
for us and they better do it exactly
according to what we are trying
scientifically speaking to express here
that doesn't work that isn't interesting
it's fine but it just isn't to me very
interesting what you need rather than
having that sort of top-down approach
institutionally speaking it's a
different idea of what an institution is
and that is the institution that is
providing a
space and an opportunity and a venue and
a way in which to get the work out into
the world as well because that I think
is equally crucial all right and just a
reminder John's going to be sticking
around
we hope you'll stick around we have that
cameras as well yeah and we will talk a
little bit about those just to just to
close up but his books are going to need
to be on sale and he'll be signing the
books if you have them as well but why
don't we talk a little more about the
cameras so we've put let's talk about
the anatomy really quickly of the of a
century camera sure I think that we even
have that there we go so there's a small
tin I don't know if we so so we have if
if you're gonna be heading straight out
we actually have some piled at the door
you can pick one up if you want to stick
around you can actually put the
finishing touches on your camera right
here and we actually have a bunch of
extras so you can get a couple if you'd
like do you want to just sort of show
sure that the camera as I said is
mercifully or shamefully simple they got
a tin can and you got a piece of paper
inside of it the paper is glued down and
the can is glued shut
before you do all of that you're going
to want to take if you have the raw
version there's already a circle drawn
you're going to cut it out you're then
going to notice that there is a center
hole there very faintly that was used to
draw the circle that's going to be your
center point for taking it putting it
down on top of the can having been cut
out it's easy to see where it goes
taking the t pin punching a hole
estimating for whether you're going to
have your camera looking out or indoors
going to mister pinhole comm if you want
to be really fussy about it knowing that
you're probably going to get it wrong
anyway but just kind of taking it as
something that you're going to attempt
anyway and then you're going to take it
you're going to glue the paper into the
back of the camera you're then going to
glue the entire camera shut take the
piece of tape off the back and then
you're basically going to
take the tape make your shutter because
it's important to have a shutter on a
hundred-year camera you'll notice I also
had a shutter on my thousand-year camera
I feel that it's a camera maybe there
should be some sort of a shot or some
sort of sense of closure so to speak so
here we have a sense of open sure so to
speak you take the camera out into the
world I mean because you're not going to
be here in hundred years presumably or
unknot so you take the camera you put it
out in the world and hide it well and
then start your exposure remember where
you put it and then tell that child we
do not have the ten euro incentive here
so this is a bit more of a leap of faith
not even attend San Francisco so it's a
barter economy or something like that is
what they talk about here let's put on a
show
actually we have an offer from Xander
you will get your ticket price back in a
hundred years so we now have a mechanism
for accountability and that's it your
camera is done you're ready to put it
out in the world and pass it on to the
next generation so if you are grabbing
one at the back you're gonna get make
sure you get one with a pin on it that
will help you make your little hole and
a piece of paper to go along with it and
we're also gonna have a video showing up
here which has been showing in the back
as well that shows you all the steps
involved and of course you're gonna ask
Jonathan more about how to do it also
thank you again so much for coming out
tonight we really appreciate it
thank you Jonathan thank you zero one
and Jamie and all of you we hope to see
you back here and if I can also yes
please thank Jamie and zero one and also
thank you for hosting me this camera is
for you this is a century camera that I
built out of an old brownie when you're
ready to take the picture
flip the shutter open a hundred years
flip it shot and you are ready to go all
right
and and I'm gonna give you a long now
challenge coin we have to get them at
the exact same thank you thanks everyone
let's have another big round of applause
[Applause]
[Music]
you